hello everyone and welcome to the third
and final day of the scaling open 2020.
now there were a lot of very interesting
games to choose from i decided to show
this one as
i don't know i felt like there was the
the it was the most action-packed game
and that you guys are going to enjoy
this one the most
but i'm probably going to cover another
one so use hashtag suggestion
uh if you want to see some other games
covered of the third day
so uh like i said uh now we're gonna see
uh
who uh will qualify for the top eight
who will uh you know
uh get past the uh eliminate the uh
preliminaries and go into the
elimination brackets
uh and uh here we have anishigiri versus
alireza ferrugia it's a very
very wild game a lot of a lot of good
attacking chess
and a lot of turn arounds throughout the
game so without further ado uh let's
check it out as
gary has the white pieces and he opens
with e4
alireza replies with c5 and we have the
sicilian defense
on the board sorry about that uh with
knight to f3 by geary
b6 and the d4 going for the open
sicilian
uh we have captures captures and now
knight to f6 so
uh very standard stuff we have knight to
c3 and now here you have many options g6
a6 e6
you can play a lot of stuff uh but here
we have knight to c6 going for the
classical variation of the sicilian
bishop to g5 the so-called director
rouser and now
e6 preparing to continue developing
those dark
uh light square and dark square bishop
uh we have queen to d2
now uh saying that i might be castling
queen side and i
probably will uh and here we have a6
taking away the b5 square from white's
knights
and now a queen side castle by geary so
he castle queen side and
should already castle king side that we
will probably see a nice king side
attack with f3 g
for h4 and so on so bishop to d7
and here f3 just strengthening this pawn
here
at some point you are probably expecting
b5 b4 so you want uh
to have this e4 pawn nicely defended
even though uh f4 is also a very popular
option even more popular than f3 here
but okay
uh bishop to e7 uh ferruja continues
developing
and now while you could start by
immediately going forward with the pawns
uh
first gear goes for the uh prophylactic
king to b1
and i don't know it's uh i guess it's a
matter of preference but i always play
the king b1 first because i've lost too
many games
uh because i haven't played king to b1
uh due to some
silly reasons either you're you know
gonna be
fall victim to some sort of tactic and
you don't want your
uh bishop uh your king to be on the same
diagonal as the queen or
maybe if the rook comes to c8 you're
gonna have problems if your king is on
the c
file or if the queen comes to a5 at some
point and you don't have the a2 pawn
defended maybe
black can also use that as a means of a
tactic
so king b1 uh always a useful
prophylactic move
uh you know most of the times so here
king b1 and now comes
knight captures on d4 this is a very
rare continuation here usually uh what
you'll see
is black playing b5 rook the c8 or queen
to c7 setting up uh
his pieces for a queen side attack but
this is somewhat rarer so obviously
furuja
testing if geary is all that well
prepared uh we have queen captures
uh grabbing back the piece and queen to
c7 now uh continuing with with the idea
rook c8 b5 still uh still
the usual moves uh we have g4 now that
everything has been said and done here
gear is ready to start pushing on the
queen side because furuja is either
coming queen
king side or he's gonna leave his king
in the in the center of the board so
here
h5 now challenging the g for pawn and
now
g captures on h5 we have knight captures
uh and
interestingly uh furuja already had this
position in the 2019 world blitz
championship he had it against alexander
grishop
uh and giri probably knew this uh as
uh hiro grisha played h4 which is uh
kind of the strongest move recommended
by the engine but he replaced rook to g1
so i don't know if gary knew about the
game but gear is uh you know
really into chess theory so i imagine he
did uh and he prepared a new idea rook
the g1
so already as of move 14 we have a
completely new game
uh now uh okay so the bishop is nicely
defended now by the rook
and here rook the c8 first just
continues developing
also one of the nice things about having
the king and b1 instead of on c1 uh
should this knight ever move
uh queen to c1 queen capture c2 will not
be checked maybe if the king was still
on c1
uh it would be checkmate uh we have
queen back to d2
now the queen also guards the bishop
here uh and
uh you could try some something else you
could try captures captures and then
rook the g5 which really wins a lot of
space for
uh for white but uh you know it's uh
it's only one of the options here geary
goes
queen to d2 and now comes b5 so the plan
is uh always pretty much
the same for black in this setup you
just have to be able to play the moves
and white will of course try
a lot of things to prevent you from
doing that so bishop to d3
uh the bishop will be very useful here
regarding the c2 pawn as the b4 could
dislodge the knight then the knight has
to move and you want
we want to have at least one more
defender defending the pawn here
we have bishop captures and g5 rook
captures on g5 now
and if queen captures also possible uh
would come with with a double attack
here but the knight is perfectly fine
defending king to f8 will also be
a nice defen defensive resource so here
we have rook captures on g5 and now
comes
b4 finally dislodging that knight knight
back to e2
and now comes queen to b6 getting the
queen out of the way
and uh in some lines preparing something
like rook c6 king e7 bringing the other
rook to c8 doubling up on the c
file and trying to uh trying to break
through of course
if white gives you a few extra moves you
might even be able to push the a pawn
and beep on the bust open
white's queen side so here f4
uh continuing to push those pawns f5
will also be an idea in some lines and
here
g6 just preventing f5 and saying okay
now i have a very nice solid position
i'm probably going to re-maneuver the
knight via some knight to f6 ids maybe
push d5 later on
but here we have knight to g3 by geary
uh f5 was also very interesting here but
it's hard to
it's hard to decide on such a move for
example captures captures now
uh you don't want the position to open
up so e5 but now
uh you know it's extremely hard
calculating uh everything out here
because it's a it's a rapid game
so you don't want to spend too much time
here so gary prepares this line
with knight the g3 now saying okay f5 is
my next move
and alireza doesn't trade here alireza
just continues uh
with his own plan knight back to f6 and
only now giri executes f5
so g captures on f5 we have e captures
on f5 and now e5 of course keeping the
center closed and now
knight to e4 guillory brings another
piece into the attack
threatening to pick up the knight with
check which would win material and here
alireza captures uh on e4 there was a
chance here
and it's uh very strange that alireza
doesn't find this because what's the
what do we always say what's the one
thing you always have to look out for
when you when you play the sicilian
uh is you know getting this d5 moving so
here d5
actually forces a trade on f6 and this
is uh
perfectly fine for black because after
captures and captures you have
this beautiful center here guarding all
of these squares your rooks are very
nicely placed
and it might look a bit scary but
[Music]
you know it it really is a massive
center so this was one of the
possibilities
alireza decides to go for knight
captures an e4 instead
bishop captures and now rook the c4
putting pressure on the bishop here
uh and now uh while the bishop is under
attack you could move it you could play
bishop d5 you could play bishop to d3
but giri plays the absolute best move
queen to g2 which guards the bishop and
also
uh keeps an eye on the rook here now
ideas like rogue g7 are possible rook j
check are possible and it's very hard
for alireza to find the move so he
starts running away with his king king
38 maybe you can
hide the king somewhere on the queen
side and now comes
bishop to d3 this was the probably the
one of the
one of the critical moments in the game
because here uh
alireza giri has to decide how to
continue and he continues with the
defensive bishop to d3 idea
what you should go is rook to g7 attack
the pawn here and
once black defends it then you have
bishop to d5 attacking the rook and the
pawn here
and of course uh giri saw this and he
thought about it but you have to take a
lot of things into consideration it's
not as easy because after for example
rook to d4
what do you play here is white and there
are a lot of things to take into
consideration because for example after
characters captures you're still not
uh welcome to to grab the pawn because
queen to d1 is checkmate and you you
kind of have to
uh calculate everything and giri doesn't
have uh
well infinite time to to dwell on this
so he goes back bishop to d3
he says i'm gonna you know create a
completely
safe defensive setup with bishop d3 and
rook to c1 and only then will i go after
this pawn create a pass pawn and win the
game
this way so here we have rook to d4
getting the recorded way also rook
uh rook c to h4 was was an option
but again i i can't stress enough how
how this is a rapid game and you don't
have all the time in the world so rook
d4
and now again you cannot move the bishop
because just captures so there might be
some plans of of uh you know just maybe
something like this
could be could be problematic for uh for
white so rook
back to c1 uh getting the rook out of
this uh
out of this d file and also i will have
help out with the defense
king to c7 first continues running with
his king
and now rook to g7 going after the pawn
here
rook to f8 and now finally queen to g5
preparing to bring the queen here and
then you're going to put pressure on the
rook you're going to put pressure on the
f7 pawn
it's going to be very difficult for
black to defend this so here
finally furuja plays d5 which opens up
the sixth rank for the black queen and
now you have to figure out what to do
here
again uh h4 here incredibly strong
because
the h file is open you just need to push
that pass pawn
all the way up the board but giri tries
a different plan he plays queen to e7
which attacks the f7 pawn attacks the
rogue but now he gives alireza
a valuable defensive resource and that
is queen to d6 and now
you either have to trade or go back but
whatever you choose
uh it's black who's uh who's calling the
shots here because after let's say
capture here
you're just gonna capture and push e4
the bishop is under attack you're gonna
win the f5 pawn next and you have a
massive center here it's just gonna be
uh it's just going to be
very awesome for black so here after
queen to d6
uh we sorry we have f6 uh by white now
defending the queen
uh and here just rook to f4 he says all
right
you either trade here or i'm just gonna
win your pawn here
so here c4 that's not a c4 here we go c4
uh prepares to open up the c file as the
king occupies it
and now uh alerza says okay queen
captures on e7
we have f captures on e7 attacking the
rook rook the e8 and only now c captures
on the e5
opening up a discovery here towards the
black king king to d6
and now bishop captures an a6 grabbing
another pawn
uh here uh gary preparing bishop to c8
after
the the rook snaps of the pawn so this
is exactly what furuja does and now
bishop to c8 and gear is now ready to go
into a a rook and pawn end game however
uh uh felucia doesn't mind this here we
have bishop captures and c8
rook captures on c8 and now king
captures on d5
and it's three pawns it each uh two
rooks uh each end game
uh where uh white has a past h pawn
also the opportunity of creating a past
a pawn uh but firuja has uh very soon to
be connected the
double pass pawns here not doubled but
connected past pawns here
uh and it's gonna be it's gonna be
pretty hard for whites to stop them so
here
look back to g2 uh and uh
now comes e4 of course viruja wants to
start pushing that pawn as quickly as
possible
rook to d2 check king e5 and now rook to
c5
with check we have king to f6 and now
king to c2 bringing the king up the
board maybe you can win this pawn this
way
uh we have rook to e5 if you wants to
trade a pair of rooks and now rook to c7
giri decides that that's that's not
happening
we have king to g6 and now king to d1
you want to get your
king here guarding against thee for pawn
uh and here first played f6 and it's a
it's a really wonderful move
because i was watching this game in the
live coverage uh i think david howell
mentioned that uh
this could have been a mouse slip why
not push the pawn all the way two
squares but
the problem here is that uh it's it's a
draw now
uh because you've allowed white to this
beautiful rook d6 check and the black
king has nowhere to go
problem is after king g5 rook g7 check
you don't have the option of going down
the board because if king h4 checked
this is just
checkmate so that's an issue so here you
would have to repeat king h5 and here
just go into a perpetual so that's why
ferruccia did not advance upon two
squares but rather only one square to f6
and again we we have a position where
it's actually okay to play f6
so rook to b7 going after the b pawn and
now
e3 attacking and defending we have rook
to g2
with check king to f5 just bringing that
king down the board uh and
now comes king to e2 stopping the pawn
also this is nicely protected so you
don't have to worry about this
uh we looked at d4 now trying rook to d2
check so king to e1 by geary
we have rook to c4 now threatening roxy
one check with the rook back to c to
check to trade off a pair of rooks
but now rook beat the g7 keeping that
rook defended uh so you don't have to
worry about this rook c1 check king to
e2 and now rook to c to check
uh and here gary goes king to d3 and now
uh you can trade here but uh the other
rook will just take this works place d2
square is nicely guarded
uh and uh well uh black uh
black will be able to capture the b
dupont if you're not uh careful and
move whoa and move this rook so uh feel
free to pause the video and find
the quickest way to win this for first
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
realizing i was only kidding when i said
this is covered because this is exactly
what you have to do
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's e2 and now you can
see
that the problem is uh the rook cannot
be captured because e1 is just queen
so you cannot allow this after e2 uh
what can you do
well well here uh rook to g1 was played
you have to
cover the the e1 square somehow point
being that if
black promotes the queen now you just
capture it and after this capture you
will capture on c2 and now white is fine
here
uh so instead after look to g1 geary
just snaps off up oh sorry alireza just
grabs the pawn uh rook captures on b2
now he's up upon
uh we have rook to e1 stopping the pass
pawn and now rook captures on a2 and now
after all is said and done
uh furuja is up two points and it's of
course a completely winning end game but
he still ha
he still needs to win it so rook to b7
going after the pawn now
king f4 uh we have rook captures on b4
uh
furuja even allows giri to capture this
pawn king of three
and now rook b to b1 uh
getting both rooks to the to the first
rank but now just king to f2
and it was in this position on move 55
that uh anishigiri resigned the game and
a brilliant brilliant victory for
alireza faruja
uh that brought him one step closer to
fi to qualifying uh for the for the
final
eight and we're gonna discuss this but
now you resign because there's nothing
more for you to do
uh you can't really move anything uh
it's it's a really terrible position you
can never
you can never move the rook otherwise
this is just uh this is just winning
and if you don't do anything just
pushing this pawn the victory will will
suffice for black
so uh before i forget uh we need to
check out
the standings the final standings after
the third day even though we're going
uh at least one more game i think uh so
let's just check that out
uh so here are the standings so in first
place uh
sharing first place is magnus carlsen
and hikaru nakamura with nine out of
fifteen points
followed by with eight and a half points
wesley so yanipanishi and levan arnan
and then uh we have with uh eight points
uh temur rajab of maxima shayla grav and
anish giri so those are the top eight
who will be
uh who will be playing in the in the
knockout phase
uh and people who have not qualified
alireza firuja
in ninth place who who won this
brilliant game against anishigiri
lakwang liam ding liran uh uh vedic
santos gujarati
uh david anton ghihara peter svidler
sergey
so some incredibly strong players fail
to qualify but
this is uh what will always happen if
you have 16 strong players
and you know if eight of them can
qualify then you will have
eight extremely strong players that
didn't qualify but it's a shame for
alireza because he played the brilliant
tournament uh but
giri played the uh in you know even
better tournament he
played brilliantly on the first day he
played brilliantly on the second day and
those two you know days of brilliant
play were enough for him to qualify even
though he didn't win a single game on
on day three he drew three games and
lost two but still he had enough points
just uh
by his great play on the first two days
so tough tough break for alireza
but we're going to see what happens in
the preliminaries these uh
are the bra this is the bracket of the
knockout so
uh as magnus carlsen finished first and
on each gear we finished eight we're
going to see carlson versus geary in
round one of the quarterfinals
eleven will face nipomishi uh wesley so
will face
timur rajabov and maxine vashilogra will
face hikaru nakamura so it's going to be
it's going to be uh pretty awesome uh
and again uh you know the the chess gods
made it so that the magnus there is a
chance we will see
a magnus cross and hikaru nakamura final
uh once again
and it it'd be just crazy to see
nakamura get one more opportunity to
take down magnus in the final but but
we'll see what happens
uh so yeah that's the game i do hope you
enjoyed it this is one i chose
i thought it was just awesome uh but
like i said do suggest uh
games you know uh i i do hope to cover
at least one more
uh before the start of the of the uh
brackets and
uh well we will see which one it will be
uh i would like to thank uh primors
filigo uh florian with
ananta ramachandra uh yandejong and
lucas bachmann for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this killing open
uh checking not open skilling uh
tournament checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and
uh whatever else happens in the chess
world uh thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day